[Music]
in part one of the rope hypothesis we
compared and contrasted quantum
establishments wave model of light
and the cloud model of the atom against
the respective thread versions we saw
how the scholars at universities all
over the world still teach their
students that ptolemee wave version of
light I have these oscillating electric
and magnetic fields that are moving
along at the speed of light mind is
certainly a terrible thing to waste
unfortunately the tender elder boys
lacked the street smartness to rebel
against such smothering Authority and
later repeat the knowledge they've
acquired with stunning candor what is it
that is waiting when a particle is
described as a way
[Music]
the right answer is existence is wavy
the particle is jumping around coming
into and out of existence the wave is a
map of the particles existence
but then existence itself is an exact at
these tiny scales but we're quantum
vibrates like a wave and mesmerizes the
choirboys is when it explains the atom
subatomic particles can disappear and
reappear in another place and they can
do this without existing in the
intervening space
[Music]
you
these particles can appear out of the
nothingness of space with such
breathtaking explanations at the college
level why would anyone need to go to
church
as a result of these amusing proposals
the quantum mathematicians end up using
three different versions of the atom to
explain phenomena the orbiting bead
model the electron cloud and the Beehive
version where countless electron beads
buzz around the nucleus simultaneously
although hydrogen has a single electron
the rope hypothesis proposes instead
that light consists of a rope that binds
any two atoms of the universe an atom is
in fact what quantum has Illustrated all
of these years a balloon the electron is
a shell that encapsulate s-- the star
like proton both the electron balloon
and the proton star are we'd by
countless threads arriving from every
atom in the universe let us now compare
the quantum mechanical bead and cloud
model against the rope hypothesis and
see how they measure up when attempting
to explain phenomena such as bonding
ionization and electricity what the
mathematicians do with their electron
bead to bind atoms into molecules is
quite scary has to make you fear further
state of mind the mathematicians get rid
of their electron bead altogether and
physically bind to hydrogen atoms with a
regions where we can find the bead
deorbiting bead or the bead that
magically appears at different locations
simultaneously Morse into a shell that
envelopes the nucleus and now this
volume or region where we can find an
electron binds to atoms into a molecule
it is not surprising that both bore and
Fineman stated that those who claim to
understand quantum mechanics are idiots
therefore anyone who tries to
rationalize quantum mechanics for you is
no different than the born-again
Christian who comes to your door to
rationalize God and salvation if the two
electron clouds are negative why don't
they push each other away
we're negative is supposed to repel each
other
same charge repel each other if
electrons get too close to each other
they'll push each other away so let's
see if the quantum mathematicians
practice what they preach in this top
example here they're overlapping in a
positive way an additive way you can
look at the overall shape that is
produced like this as an oval they can
add in a negative way in which one is
subtracted so to speak from the other
it's like this hydrogen atom right here
being positive and this hydrogen atom
being negative put them together they're
going to cancel each other out and
instead of producing a nice big oval
like this the electrons though this area
right here just kind of is subtracted
electrons will not be found here they
won't be found in the node because
that's just an area that's been
cancelled out they can't exist there
it's absolutely stunning that the
quantum mathematicians are still unable
to give you a straightforward
explanation to this most fundamental of
molecules when the answer has been
staring at them in their faces all of
these years it is patently obvious that
they are gawking at two balloons being
pushed against each other
indeed the mathematicians simulate
electron orbitals in the classroom with
balloons when two atoms are spinning in
the same direction say clockwise the
rope unwinds and the electron shells
continue merging coupling like two balls
of yarn forming the characteristic
figure-eight pattern and later The Oval
electron shell of the hydrogen gas
molecule if one atom is spinning
clockwise and the other counterclockwise
they flatten out and form the
characteristic node clearly the infamous
orbital of mathematics is not a region
where we can find an electron bead but
what the chemists have assumed it to be
for decades
hmm the rope hypothesis suggests that
this membrane is weaved by countless
electromagnetic threads arriving from
every atom in the universe
both quantum mechanics and the electric
universe hold that an atom is ionized if
it loses an electron marble a negative
ion is an atom or molecule that has
gained one or more extra negatively
charged electrons in order to sell the
snake-oil to the crowd the Mathemagician
converts the cloud back to a bead does
the cloud or region without an electron
in it now interact with other regions
and form molecules it would certainly
help it's a quantum scholars were able
to tell you what physical entity kept
the electron bead bound to the proton in
the first place how does a bowling ball
physically attracted tennis ball for
instance the mathematicians allege that
sodium donates its outer electron to
chlorine to physically form an ionic
bond in the molecule we call salt a
sodium atom has one valence electron a
chlorine atom has seven valence
electrons if the atoms collide with
sufficient energy the chlorine atom will
remove the electron from the sodium the
mathematician state that the outer shell
of sodium is no longer there so what is
it that physically keeps the two atoms
together now sodium has neither an outer
electron bead nor orbital
and why is the mysterious entity the
mathematicians call energy higher
between the atoms
under the rope model the threads
comprising the outer shells of an atom
are swinging around the entire shell is
spinning thus whereas a strong covalent
bond occurs when the shells merge a
weaker ionic bond takes place
electrostatically the threads of the
outer shell of one atom spin in one
direction and those of its neighbors
spin in another the mathematicians refer
to these opposite directions as positive
and negative in physics however there is
no such thing as positive and negative
there is only rotation the two atoms are
drawn together because the threads
coming downwards engage the threads
swinging upwards think of this as two
people skipping rope in the same
direction this region of high activity
is what the mathematicians call higher
energy the lower energy elsewhere
results because there is no interaction
between threads in the religion of
mathematics electricity consists of a
flow of electron ping-pong balls from
one atom to another for this the
mathematicians again morph the electron
cloud back into a bead
if an outside electric pressure or
voltage is applied to a conductor the
electrons will move predominantly in one
direction the effect is that the
electrons move from the negative to the
positive terminal this is the electric
current an atom has electrons orbiting
the nucleus our electricity is is moving
electrons
electricity is the movement of charged
atomic particles called electrons
flowing electrons are called current
electrons start to move traveling from
the negative terminal towards the
positive terminal this is electricity an
atom has a positively charged center
called the nucleus and you have
negatively charged electrons orbiting
around it but since the negatively
charged electrons repel each other when
you move one electron from atom to atom
you'll also move other electrons from
atom to atom an electric circuit is a
closed loop where current can flow
around electrons can flow from the
battery through the copper wire to the
other side of the battery all the
electrons are moving at the same time
over here the negative terminal of the
battery is pushing the negative
electrons away and those electrons are
pushing other electrons away the actual
flow of electrons goes from negative to
positive quantum mechanics and the
electric universe invoked the amusing
planetary model of the atom to theorize
about ionization on electricity
however the electron bead model proposes
that you can receive a shot even if
you're not in contact with a live wire
an electron bead may jump to an atom in
your hand
quantum electricity makes no provision
for contact between atoms there is no
physical explanation for how or why an
electron jumps to divide and still you
wonder why the electron beads float into
your body
what desperate demand does your body
have four electron beads under the rope
model of the atom electron shells merged
to form a row of aligned atoms this
serpentine spins swinging threads around
itself
Faraday referred to this invisible
mechanism as a magnetic field with the
electron serpentine model of electricity
we can readily see why there must be
physical contact between your skin and a
wire your entire body is now physically
connected to the grid the zap that you
receive is a torsion of countless
interconnected electrons
all's that now extend into your body
in the next video we will look at threat
theories version of the neutron and
explore how it fits into the puzzle
[Music]
[Music]